no
clark county teachers and
students back to school today
how are you greeted by cristian cásseres even
though there will be some empty desks
after high kobe case numbers 19
school sector officials say
the five-day break allowed them to
school district nurses to
organize and track all absences
for kobe and i hope the magician who had
plans to use tigers in his show by
storing them in a sanctuary in the
hotel zone has withdrawn his
original plan now winehouse say he will
request the use of a vacant lot
near paris and it will be to perform his
show without the use of the tigers
this new plan will be presented to the
commissioners next month las vegas
will host the biggest event
in music the
grammy awards will take place next 3
april at mgm grand the event is
normally held in los angeles
but the rise in covite cases prompted a
change of cities l  he big ones will be
broadcast on channel 8
and we close with a look at the
temperatures we continue to have
nice days with temperatures in the 60s
as you can see today we will have a
sunny day totally the opposite of the
rainy day we saw yesterday
we have strong winds for the  Friday
and Saturday throughout the valley I am
Cristian Cásseres with
ginseng informative insurance to a Spanish good day
[Music]